I think the radio right now the top
three companies in the second make this
change the number of sameness of formats
as well
top three or top 47 format song and a
lot of sports talk formats on and these
are reflective of the ratings
methodology and also the budget cuts at
radio stations I also did not like the
way my intellectual property was handled
in the radio business my podcasts and
what-have-you were treated in a kind of
Cavalier manner and so I wanted to
control lane lateral property and I also
wanted to do something that was
cutting-edge and fun radio because of
its budget budgetary concerns has never
been technologically ahead of the game
they've made many bad decisions about
technology over the years of the 80s the
attempt to promote something called AM
stereo big failure and now they have
something called HD radio which has been
a non-starter for most customers and
radio business well nobody jumps ship to
online radio they are pushed that's you
know
like you know it's a lot easier to just
come in every day clock is and talking
microphone I'm in Cracow I mean you know
being here you have to be willing to
sign on as an entrepreneur I'm involved
in every aspect of this you know what I
went to the radio station I'd show up at
2:58 and like we go on three and I'd
start talking and then at 7:01 I would
leave that was it here I have to wait we
just said door put it in the back here
and to make sure that the alarm company
came I'm gonna have to do all all the
grunge works and people at the radio
station would normally do though the
fact is though they I have pride of
ownership here I'm thrilled to get
involved in these little details and
deviling the tails to worry about I'm
especially thrilled when I see the final
product you know and all this hard work
turns into this show that we come out
with every if people have no idea what
went into getting the first show on on
the stream how much was going wrong and
how I had to crack the whip over people
just to get them to do their jobs on
time and people didn't understand that
we were a lot closer to d-day than they
than they imagined but Gary and I have
been through the war we know how much
work it takes to get a show up and
running yeah when I went to work at
Westwood One in 1994 we had to get my
syndicated show up to 22 station I had
six weeks and we were working in a
studio that had no no phone system no
delay over the years the studio had not
been used for a long time and they were
like just big holes where our equipment
should go
and so we had six weeks to cobble the
phone number even believe how much time
it takes to cope with one eight hundred
five hundred on like we used to have or
like that one
thumb and though the cadence that people
can remember stupid things like that I
actually take a lot of work so to have
all these details you know people listen
to radio and it just kind of comes out
of the radio and oh and by the way
Lister shouldn't worry about that stuff
not there prominently they should turn
it on and get a show but the reality is
there's a lot of things you have to do
to make that happen
and around here I you should have seen
these surprised look what I walked in
Burbank Water and Power and you gave the
deposit to turn on the electricity in
this building like why was I there well
what are you doing here and then I was
there because it's my company and I had
to sign the paperwork at CBS when I were
to kill that sex I couldn't tell you who
turned off the electricity there and it
was responsible where I wouldn't have
any idea so literally everything
everything from putting these flat
screens in here to the software we use
the up content up to switching over from
GoDaddy to triton digital for our
streaming and for our metrics these are
decisions I don't leave that to other
people there's no general manager here
I'm the owner and I have to make these
decisions every day every day as always
I don't do that the studio I do that at
home I work on this morning people know
good likes to be posting all things so
I'm there from early every morning and
I'm looking you know I'm looking at what
people are talking about my life because
that's the best way to know what what
the audience is excited about I throw
stuff out there and I see what catches
and what doesn't and when I throw
something up here that seems to get a
response but that becomes the three
o'clock top but I may throw several
things out there and I think I may be
mediocre some of them may get a good
response
some people get an unbelievable response
and I
Michael's that that's that's what we go
with for storage also there are certain
predetermined features on a show like we
did money Monday today that's every
Monday so you know there's no such thing
as that by the way when I do a monologue
there are no notes
I don't read from a teleprompter or cue
cards or index cards that is live and
totally spontaneous and I've always
worked that way and always will so you
know it's not like I have to sit home
and type up my monologue I've been
committed read it it doesn't work that
way I never ever results correctly
negative commercials that were never
show we have the Amazon which is
substantial surprise and the podcasting
that's that's well into the six figures
for a year most podcasts don't see six
figures and five years and so I'm
thrilled that you know that triumvirate
of revenue streams is gonna work for us
only you know they'll be more coming
from ad agencies and media buyers now
that we have accredited metrics from
trying digital that are accredited just
like Arbitron is accredited in radio so
we don't have to beg for scraps we can
walk in proudly with these numbers and
show them to the media buyers the
advocates you sent I know we're going to
have a lot of cooperation you know I've
been in this business my whole life I
know a lot of people would be ad agency
is a lot of the media buyers and there
was no way I was going to do it
content creators man they don't worry we
have lots of emails from people we a a
lot of people post on our Facebook page
no no that wasn't enough I needed to
have an accredited numbers that showed
that people were listening to the
product and who they are and we know
what cities that from countries they're
from what what browsers they use with
who use a media player which media
clearly we know everything about and we
don't use estimates we use actual
numbers so you know based on my own
experience could be I had ABC media
buyers and the you know the people who
may make these things happen
I don't think we're gonna have much of a
problem based on how it might be if you
want to succeed at producing content
from the internet you first have to make
sure that you don't like your home
working you don't how to make it sound
great it should not be an ordeal or an
effort to hear your content and then
many times Internet content offering
there's sound problems people don't sit
close up to the laptop with a snowball
microphone they sound like they're in
the other room you really have to look
at that stuff because the listener cares
about that they know how to voice it to
you in a tweet but they may know and
secondly you have to have a devotion to
providing fresh content whether it's on
a weekly basis or a daily basis people
have to know what time your content is
coming down the pipe and then it has to
come down on time every day
the reason radio said life in ninety
years was because you knew every day
there was going to be a new episode of
Rick Dees a new episode of Howard Stern
you knew when it came on you knew how
long it was going to be if you want to
make a business out of it if you want to
make a career out of it you have to
deliver fresh content on a reliable
schedule
and not give those [ __ ] excuses that
you didn't have time and do your [ __ ]
podcast that it pisses me off no and
when people say that and I think it
pisses off your audience if you're
building audiences
yes what evening download your pumpkins
they're your fans they expect if it's
Monday morning at 5:00 a.m. that your
podcast is supposed to be released
guess what is 500 or a thousand people
expecting that to happen and you can't
you can't just say well I didn't have
time but you'll be relegated permanently
as a an amateur if that's your attitude
one thing about being professional
haven't been to the radio business all
the years is I know that at 3 o'clock
every afternoon there's a lot of people
who want to hear what I have to say at
that time and there's no such thing as
just saying I didn't feel like doing
Tuesday